[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yes Jesus gracias hola bienvenidos kuba
hello
you're so he's impressed y'all so I
caught on O'Brian e lo siento pero
that's all the Spanish I can really
memorize as many of you know this is a
very historic time relations between
Cuba and the United States are finally
starting to thaw I thought it was an
amazing opportunity for me to come to
Cuba talk to the people get to know them
we have an incredible show for you isn't
that right Cuban and II see you're more
agreeable than the real Andy used to be
easy for Americans to visit Cuba in the
1940s and 50s it was the Las Vegas of
the Caribbean but in 1959 Fidel Castro
led a revolution that toppled the
dictatorship of Fulgencio Batista which
led to a u.s. economic blockade that has
lasted for 53 years then in December of
last year President Obama announced he
wanted to normalize relations with Cuba
establish formal diplomatic ties and
pending congressional approval lift the
embargo Cuba is a country with many
complicated social and political
problems so this process won't be easy
which is why I kept the purpose of my
visit simple to meet the people and try
to make friends
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
how much that that went well what women
love me here dogs hate me
these are everywhere this is a Cuban
payphone as you can tell it's pretty
distinctive it enables you to make a
call and get your hair permed at the
same time the only problem is it will
only call that talking to that guy right
oh no with that I was a little worried
that my Spanish wouldn't be good enough
here in Cuba but now I think I'll be
okay
[Music]
this is a mercado or market here in Cuba
pretty typical let's take a look look at
this you just don't see this anywhere
else whole row of just one product one
brand that's it I don't know what this
is veno Seco sweet wine at a window but
just goes and goes and goes
we cannot film here not not without
authorization I think we I mean it's
okay I don't need to I was just
wondering if you had any I'm just be no
Seco
at window you have that
okay